hey this is tour check me out on the
bulay kev podcast the biggest triple
waves but let's get it
yo bootleg cab show we got a special
guest in here what's going on man
to where
welcome welcome hey first of all
congratulations on this cupid record
appreciate it bro it's going crazy um
it's very much like some jersey club
music type vibes but you're from philly
yeah philly club so it's philly so
there's a thing in philly
like that like i didn't know club music
was in philly i've never been to philly
so you gotta educate me no club music oh
he's been in philly forever we just like
you know just start rapping on it like
making that [ __ ] global type [ __ ] so
yeah but we've been dancing to it and
all that like you know so
have you ever been random question have
you ever been to chester pennsylvania
yeah i know a lot of those that was one
of my like first like real drones like
how crazy
crazy because i drove through uh i took
the train from dc to new york and it
stopped in chester
and that should look like a [ __ ] war
zone that shit's small but it's crazy
like you found me it's small like it was
easy to get that fan base for for like
coming from philly
all the chesters and delaware yeah right
that whole area even like parts of
jersey right mm-hmm
yeah um
do you would you consider yourself
influenced by other philly rappers
because you don't sound like no
you know i guess the generation before
you for sure you know
i'm influencing everybody else
you feel like you're influencing the
city now everybody else bro everybody
that [ __ ] crazy is that crazy to like
hear other people try to do what you're
doing oh yeah
they'd be mimicking that [ __ ] like
nobody was rapping melodic on that [ __ ]
i started that melodic hook [ __ ] on
there like like really like you know
like [ __ ] copy off of that
[ __ ] copy off from what i wear
the pants like
so you weren't growing up like listening
to like freeway and [ __ ] and like the
roots and
maybe meek mill maybe yeah me meek but
none of the another like i listened to
freeway but i was like more like my
step-pop uncle gotcha type [ __ ] not me
though finally listen to freeway like
that but me yeah meek yeah yeah shout
out to meek has he reached out to you
yeah he reached out to me before
you don't sound too excited about me
now you reached out to me before i ain't
going you know are you cool do you try
to sign you to dream chasers
yeah you could see that here he tried to
sign you he sent somebody to try to sign
me to dream chases here so he sent
something like someone to try to recruit
you yeah why not um
why didn't he come himself boss i don't
know
you don't know so it was a no
had he came himself pause
would you would you have maybe given it
like more consideration yeah for sure
yeah yeah that's what's up shout out to
me i [ __ ] with me though nah but i don't
know i don't i don't i ain't not gonna
be the artist designer and even no other
artist anyway though like i smarted my
own [ __ ] you know yeah that's smart
let's do that yeah do you have your own
company now
yeah unless you started what's that
rare
just rare yeah it's really entertaining
right now but i might switch it up
you've been changing i gotta get an
official name like they're really get
the chain with the logo yeah
speaking of chains that's a serious uh
piece of jewelry you got there
something like that what's it running
you shh i don't want to talk about that
hit the pockets pretty serious yeah hit
the pockets
let me give you some advice they're
young mm-hmm
i ain't [ __ ] the money up on jewelry
no but listen
well clearly you are [ __ ] up some
money on jewelry i see it
but when you're in a studio session
and the jeweler comes to the studio
session that is a red flag yeah a
hundred percent why do you say that
because they are taxing they're putting
so much money on like those kind of
jewelers that will pull up to the studio
with the little suitcase
with the handcuff and then they show you
all the [ __ ] that they brought
run away
ain't nobody never did that to me but
they will
especially if you're out in l.a more
yeah you're gonna just be hanging out
with a studio movies someone's gonna
pull up with like [ __ ] there's gonna
be the guy who comes with like 10 pounds
of weed trying to sell you weed even
though you don't smoke and then they'll
be the jeweler who tries to like
sell you you know you end up like with a
little baby fake you know watch you know
what i'm saying remember when that
happened
i seen that [ __ ] did you go through the
proper precautions to make sure your
watch wasn't
hey diamond tested whatever yeah right
right i did that
yeah you got to get the diamond test you
just keep that on deck no i don't keep
it on deck by me sure like before i even
you know left that [ __ ]
i had to ask you because
you look a lot younger than you are
you're 22 years old or a grown ass man
it's the braces though
the braces
i think we need to normalize more people
getting their teeth together
because i feel like some people i know
people who are adults who need braces
right
and they won't get them because it's
like they're too old yeah yeah i feel
like i've seen 30 year old 40 year olds
with braces and [ __ ] really being that
ted she's see 30 or 40 year olds who
need braces all right they got their
teeth all [ __ ] up you know what i'm
saying see that [ __ ] alive
and then they just throw in the towel
and go to colombia and get those [ __ ]
veneers right those [ __ ] chompers
thank god you ain't get the chompers
back well i do want something you don't
want those no i just don't want them
doing like horse teeth like you don't
walk around here looking like [ __ ]
a.d from no jumper that's my guy
i'mma [ __ ] got like teeth this should
look like dentine ice you know what i'm
saying i am hey what up it's bootleg kev
we got to stop the interview to tell you
what our good friends at my bookie
football season has started my favorite
time of the year because i love to
gamble on football it makes watching
football so much fun it's my like
literally i just love watching football
and i love it even more when i got money
on the line and no matter where you are
right now what state what country you
can get in on the action it's a winning
season go to my bookie sign up for a new
account register and get that double
deposit bonus using the promo code
bootleg now let me tell you what that
means that means when you go to my
bookie let's say you make a 250 deposit
using the promo code bootleg you'll have
500 to gamble with that's right they're
gonna double your [ __ ] money right
now they got the prop builder you could
bet on whether or not i don't know
well matthew stafford throw for three
touchdowns will kylo murray rush for a
touchdown you could put all those on one
thing and secure the [ __ ] bag
all right get online with your boy let's
get this money together my bookie go
sign up with that promo code bootleg and
double your deposit right now go
register yeah but uh uh talk about uh
obviously getting dirk on the record
dirk is out we just had a conversation
with little zay osama about dirk and
like
he's kind of like uh
you know we talk about the drake
stimulus package there's the dirk
stimulus package like if dirk gets on
your [ __ ] these days it's a big deal
right like uh how did that happen
[ __ ] he had hit me up he hit me like two
months ago like send me a line he he
wanted to um like put me on his deluxe
at first he was like yo i'm trying to
put you in my deluxe you feel me send me
like two to three opens i sent them cute
bit i sent them a song called linemen
that i got out right now and another
song
but
when i sent them you know like the
sample [ __ ] and all that type stuff so
he was like damn i just talked to my ceo
he basically said that we might not be
able to clear it on time type [ __ ] so
i'm like alright but [ __ ] we gonna do
something so long street short
like a week go by later he performing at
summer jam and [ __ ] i'm backstage some
gym by myself
feeling me i heard i heard i'm like yo
dirk you feel me dirt coming out of that
i'm like oh dirty people for him because
he's like he wanted to really lock in
with me like on some atl metro [ __ ]
right right so like once i heard he was
there i straight faced tiny mission like
where are you at i don't even know
brushy i flipped my camera i was right
in front of the [ __ ] trailer yeah
pulled me in on that joint and [ __ ] kind
of like 400 thousand my face busted out
and all that type of [ __ ] kid forty
thousand dollars in cash in your yeah
yeah he yeah
is that what they paid him to do
something i don't know that [ __ ] i was
like you know this [ __ ] real you feel me
so once i seen that shot i asked him
about the record that [ __ ]
he said like he he like a little iffy
about it but he was like i really want
to do something from scratch with you
but i'm like all right [ __ ] it bang like
a week go by later and [ __ ] man we
always kept in touch like we talked like
every day
so i texted him i woke up one morning
like [ __ ] i'm gonna shoot my shot
again i'd say something like yo broski
like how much i got you to hop on the
song ain't text me back to like no know
hannah text me he called me later on
like seven o'clock i touched him
probably like 12 o'clock in the
afternoon he called me like yo broski i
got my own daughter on the phone
and he was like show your face like she
don't believe that i know he was i
showed my face i'm like yo she started
smiling and [ __ ] i'm like damn
hey bro how much you want to really out
when i joined you like send me that [ __ ]
right now i'm in the lab
sent me that [ __ ] out like the next hour
and it was up so did you have to pay him
no i didn't so he just did it on the
street did that [ __ ] he did that big
deal man that [ __ ] [ __ ] cashed me off
for my birthday all type [ __ ] she gave
me money yeah what kind of like what
what's the birthday gift looking like
she gave me five grand five bands yeah
was this at a strip club or was this
just oh is that the video shoot wow
[ __ ]
what'd you do with the fight bands
shawn you want to talk about that [ __ ]
bro what happened what happened with the
money
give me the story
all right tell you this [ __ ] bro that
[ __ ] that night
all blues you feel me
i i have probably like two to three
wrecks you feel me on the side i put
together with that [ __ ] i'm on ocean
drive okay you're in miami um on the
lookout yeah yeah we out in front of
there [ __ ] i had my money on the side of
the car and [ __ ] my homie was playing on
my money my homie was playing my money
and [ __ ] my brother peeped it
so dang after that [ __ ]
after i came out my brother told me i
put this [ __ ] in the glove department
and [ __ ] man my money out there my homie
ain't still that [ __ ]
so i had um put the money in the glove
apartment i hopped on this [ __ ] zoom
car and [ __ ] i fall asleep after the
zoom call me riding to the airport bro i
leave my money in the [ __ ] car and
brother reno please brother i ain't
noticed it to like 20 to 30 minutes
later bro i try to run back i hop on the
shuttle bus i came back hey yo unlock
the door right now they unlock the door
i go in the glad apartment they took all
my hunnids bro and left me once
i'm making them empty pockets all types
of [ __ ] bro you just snapping this [ __ ]
literally probably like four days ago
like jesus i'm snapping so it was five
grand plus more money it was more money
probably like 7 thousand for a few they
came up whoever that was then he said a
[ __ ] that checked the car and all that
he had got off oh he was gone i'm like
he probably quit his job he's like [ __ ]
this job that's what i'm saying you
feeling me i was hot don't hang on like
[ __ ] [ __ ] me up seven bands man in front
of the finger licking
so now that she was at the room yeah
yeah you took the car back do you like
uh
the uh mystery drink there
yeah that's actually good looking yeah
that's a good [ __ ] did you go to the
booby trap on the river no not yet we
want the kiki on the river we ain't go
to the booby trap you gotta go to booby
trap i wanted to go there did you give
any money to any lovely uh miami uh you
know single mothers
single mothers yeah
no you
know if you're in the strip club with a
girl and she has an only fans will you
subscribe on the spot just to show her
you're a real one [ __ ] no no i ain't
done that what if it's free but just
like a free subscribe you know i ain't
doing that i might try to fake it like
i'm showing i love but i ain't doing
that i ain't watching this [ __ ] none of
that you never you never subscribed to
an only fans account
wow
i just was never like really into that
[ __ ] right do that you ever like go to
high school [ __ ] what about like this
like maybe you grew up with a chick
right and now she's got an only fan
you're just not curious
like you know i've known you for like 10
years let me just see what it looks like
no [ __ ] be weird too yeah i don't know
they'd be weird not me before of course
not you lying i wouldn't do that you
look like you lying
he's lit like
i would never you like you did that like
i like my money i'm not giving it away
yeah oh no no none of that [ __ ] that man
hey that's that's over with appreciate
y'all watching but listen our partners
at blue chew they got you handled fellas
and etc whatever you are they got it if
you got a dick blue chew is for you
because they will make sure your dick
performs at all time levels i mean like
lebron his first three seasons with the
heat type levels i mean your wife will
thank you for it everybody will thank
you for it [ __ ] even if you just take a
blue chew and jerk your dick it's a it's
a stronger jerk i swear to god
stronger [ __ ] jerk for sure you're gonna
be beating your dick like i stole
something
so what you got to do is go to
bluetooth.com right now
use the promo code bootleg right now and
you're going to get your first month
free and this is the great thing about
bluechew the same active ingredients as
viagra and as cialis
but you don't got to go to the doctor's
office yeah who wants to go hang out at
the doctor's office and be like hey doc
you got some [ __ ] pills for me nobody
wants to do that no you sign up at blue
chew use the promo code bootleg and
you're getting your first month
delivered to your door
in discreet packaging i'm telling you
you're going to thank me later all right
if you've gotten bluetooth already just
dm me tell me just
just dm me no photos just tell me how
you know let me just tell you it's
[ __ ] amazing our producer cyrus's
daddy 70 took the blue chew he's [ __ ]
just beating down all the senior citizen
[ __ ] available in arizona right now so
go to bluetooth.com use that promo code
bootleg or just hit the link in the
description of this video let's get back
to the interview are you a single man
you're a taken man what's going on [ __ ]
complicated shit's complicated yeah i'm
seeing it over
well good for you man i feel like uh
this part in your career
you gotta enjoy the uh
draw the uh you know the uh fish in the
ocean there's a lot of them that [ __ ]
don't be like
genuine to me so i don't really be
feeling really like interacting or
engaging with that [ __ ] because i'll be
feeling all that [ __ ] yeah the dms are
pretty wild huh oh yeah
pretty crazy i'm sure you gotta and you
gotta be careful i feel like all kinds
of
you know you probably got some young
fans probably
leave me the [ __ ] alone i'm a grown-ass
man
yeah you gotta break down the haircut
man
so you got
i've been to a barber battle before
so you and your boy got the lines so for
people who are not hip to
what's going on with the line across
your because you got a real chiseled
hairline but it's also like
drawn in yeah
educate us educate me and the rest of
the white people watching this who are
[ __ ] disconnected all [ __ ] think
this [ __ ] chalk for real for for the
most part but it's not it's like a
barber pencil that make the haircut like
pop out more [ __ ] but we started a whole
trend in the city where like we got all
the kids on it shouldn't be putting
flour on the head and all that type of
[ __ ] but flour like that you bake with
it yeah bro white flour all types of
[ __ ] like really crazy oh yeah that
shit's wild right so would you because
i've seen i've seen this before but like
i've never seen like an artist really
pop it off so like would you say you're
kind of trying to set that trend yeah
yeah oh yeah everything market
everything on market everything
marketable i'm trying to hit the world
on this [ __ ] mm-hmm
kim kardashian just posted your song
which is uh seems like you know a pretty
big deal yeah it's crazy that she [ __ ]
me up i was on miami when i seen that
too
was she uh like
did you have any heads up that was gonna
happen
um that [ __ ] just happened i seen
somebody tell me in the comments i
clicked that [ __ ] mind you she took her
real off of her page like you could do
remove from me
from your profile but it's still on
there right you're still on it
but i'm like i'm like i'm i'm looking
around like that [ __ ] fake well then i
clicked the real like no that [ __ ] up
there like people tagged me all in that
[ __ ] i'm like damn that's crazy it was
the first day i dropped cupid with the
audio that's crazy yeah bro i said that
[ __ ] the dirt he like yo that [ __ ] heavy
that's hard
did uh
like did you notice like a spike like
right away or i mean it was the first
day it dropped so you really didn't
really tell the difference the
difference right i should have been
spiking though like yesterday the day
before my monthlies and all that what
about just like did you get a bunch of
followers on ig after she posted it no
no
she ain't tagged me in it but that [ __ ]
was still you heard me
shout out to uh kim kardashian yeah
she's the same out of five man she's
like on the mount rushmore of
the spank bank
yeah let's just make me bro it's like uh
you know if you had to pick like four or
five chicks who you want hits are you
[ __ ] yeah like in your head are you
crazy so be like oh [ __ ] on your spin
kim
that's all on your [ __ ] yeah nikki
who else
rihanna's not bad
vita guerra from like 2003
who's on your spank bank
no names man
no days there's chicks from north philly
that you personally know hell no i'm off
the north philly chicks
no you don't got one check that like you
just grew up like man if i could ever
get the chance i was like yeah i did
something with them already
so rihanna you wouldn't want to [ __ ]
rihanna is that what you're telling me
oh wait
rihanna's in a relationship with him
we got to be respectful
he can't be burning my bridges already
man i'm just there we got to be
respected
at least there's somebody singing like
sweetie
label mate
you do a song together
oh no you could do the murder beats
anita thing they're label mates i'm not
sure how real that relationship is you
know i'm gonna hum all of them yeah
yeah that you you say you won't you
don't have to hump all of them no damn
shout out to the hump man i ain't heard
that one in a while get it humphy um
what obviously this record's going crazy
but like uh body of work is that coming
down the pipeline yeah for sure
i already got that [ __ ] for real is it
done
it's just about right now we working on
singles and [ __ ] like that trying to pop
this [ __ ] up get this [ __ ] like gold
platinum type [ __ ] really get this [ __ ]
going but other than that yeah we got
that [ __ ] in store who else uh do you
have uh features with or do you want to
have features with oh i want to have
features of it i got i got a bunch of
fees i just been doing i just started
doing features for referral but
i want to do a feature with future drake
like them type [ __ ] like future
and drake yeah future drake nikki
future has been official i [ __ ] don't
want to do it
problem with future is it'll charge you
250 thousand dollars
that's the only thing i don't want i
don't want to pay for that [ __ ] i saw
megan say that and i was like damn megan
ain't even get the discount i'd rather
get this [ __ ] really going and then you
know
yeah
but even
megan is really going right still got
hit for 250. that's crazy that's
surprising you think like megan would
they'd be like a yo we'll do a swap you
know what i mean yeah yeah you're right
now you owe durka swap
that's for sure so now you got a problem
you think you asked me if i'm gonna do
that [ __ ] yeah i mean plus you gave you
five grand
but you lost the money because you're
irresponsible obviously
who the [ __ ] leaves five thousand
dollars in a glove compartment what is
going on here bro having too much [ __ ]
going on you gotta go to the bank and
deposit that [ __ ] or give it to a single
mother at booby trap on the river no i
should have got another heaven and you
know i'm just happy did you like miami's
like one of those cities that
if you're there you could be like man
i love it so much but if i lived here
i might get
really lost in the sauce out here sure
how'd you feel about miami because when
i was out there i was like if i lived
here i love miami i'd end up divorced
but that [ __ ] like you really outside
out there like
and like
the night starts at two in the morning
[ __ ] was like yo meet me at the
spot at 2 45 i'm like bro that [ __ ] get
back ocean drive all that yeah no you
gotta like yeah
you gotta go to tootsies next time
tusties two teasers yeah yeah you ever
been to tizzy's no that's where drake
was getting shoulder rubs you know yeah
yeah what's that like
they got um just like ladies walking
around giving you massages for
20 bucks a song
yeah and they have uh
amazing food they have a
deep fried lobster tail
with seafood rice
you'll change your life that should
sound crazy how is the food in philly
because from what i gather it looks like
everyone just talks
cheesesteaks was it ish bibbles i heard
about to about
his fire yeah that's fire what's the
spot though like what is like the spot
like that's like obviously everyone
knows about the big the big like [ __ ]
popping chains but yeah
we've been eating everything lately
everything we've been
getting is freaked so we've been eating
everything that look good and [ __ ] like
but yeah i don't understand rocking
flavors all types of like leds like we
just like like when we go to the city
they hit us up or we see some [ __ ] that
we like from this city we hit them up
and they but yeah come on
nice like we eat all types of different
[ __ ] we don't eat the same thing like
are you still in the last time i ate a
cheese stick are you still like staying
in billy
yeah you could say that i was great for
philly nice
do you uh feel like because i feel like
when [ __ ] really starts to like get
moving it's almost like
the worst
idea is to stay home yeah you got more
haters
miami la new york i've really been going
to new york a lot too
yeah i feel like new york la or atlanta
atlanta yeah atlanta i just came from
atlanta too has uh gillian wallow tapped
in with you yet yeah he [ __ ] with me
yeah i was just talking about it before
i came on her great guy and [ __ ] told
me to stay out of philly stay focused
and stay out of philly smart yeah
i feel like you're having fun with this
[ __ ] a lot of artists in your uh like
your peers are very like they're not fun
guys all right it's a lot of op killing
music bro right [ __ ] is serious
like you're having fun it's like
refreshing to see somebody new
having fun right
it's like man [ __ ] is
every time like someone sends me some
new [ __ ] and i personally i'm like jesus
christ
same [ __ ] girl yeah it's just
and even if it ain't from
everybody [ __ ] with the drill [ __ ]
though you look like you [ __ ] with it
like
that
i tell you what i like
have you heard the song dojo by central
c
yeah i [ __ ] with this one this is
[ __ ] hilarious
when he says
hugging my brother said tell him i love
him but i don't swing that way
[Laughter]
yeah
no the drill [ __ ] is like i feel like
i'm just like my age i'm i'm 35 years
old
all respected dirk yeah
but with dirk drops an album i'll get to
it i'm not running to it you know what
i'm saying
the nba young boy [ __ ]
totally
just
collection of records i [ __ ] with
but you know i just feel like there's
some of this [ __ ] i'm just i'm just i'm
just i'm just like i'm listening to
[ __ ] benny the butcher and freddie
gibbs you know what i mean griselda like
everybody got their own opinion on type
though
we got to stop the interview tell you
about our partners at odd socks well
first of all let's check out the brand
new collab
look at these
the bootleg kev sock you see my pink ass
face on those [ __ ] socks nobody wants
to buy those we're gonna figure out a
way to give them away though uh but look
odd socks the most comfortable socks in
the world um and the best thing about
odd socks is they're our family man i've
been walking with these guys for about
10 years now and i will not wear
anything else on my feet like i swear to
god i'm about to take my shoe off i'm
going to take the look what is this
smells great too that's an odd sock
right there that's awesome basic you
know what i'm saying we [ __ ] with odd
socks you should too they got the crazy
licenses we're talking about nickelodeon
shout out to patrick [ __ ]
cheez-its
baywatch
how about macaroni underwear look at
these boys right here let's just crack
these [ __ ] open real quick what
do we got in here
come on man
yeah a little pop-tart underwear yeah i
mean
yeah these are the odd socks basics all
right so if you go to the website right
now order you some underwear order you
some socks use the promo code bootleg
kev that's one word altogether bootleg
kev and you will save 20 off at checkout
go to
oddssoxofficial.com one more time that's
oddssodgeofficial.com
promo code bootleg kev and you will save
20 off your order of course we're
presented by odd socks and we are proud
to say so all right let's get back to
the interview
yeah and then you know
i started watching yellowstone have you
seen yellowstone
it's a tv show no
it's got me tapping in with the country
low-key i mean yeah i ain't never
watched yellowstone i've never heard of
it it's got kevin costner and it's about
a ranch
[ __ ] super popping should check it out
what are you watching on tv so i'm
watching bmf
um what else i'm watching
i'll be watching stranger things
hey season four was crazy things yeah
season four was crazy would you ever get
into acting yeah that's what i want to
do i feel like you're made for that [ __ ]
like a lot i'll audition for bellaire oh
really yeah
my homie got the rule and [ __ ] i just
became an extra on the first episode of
[ __ ] oh so you were in the first episode
yeah that's dope i just seen the whole
thing like the makeup and how they
behind the scene like i really want to
do that [ __ ] that's smart dude you got a
great personality and i feel like
don't like limit yourself to this music
no i want to do like right now i just
got started on the merc [ __ ] merch for
me you're doing the dancing and all that
[ __ ]
acting i wanna do a lot of [ __ ] people
ain't gonna like me for music they gonna
let me [ __ ] you know
[ __ ] like uh snoop dogg yeah snoop dogg
is like he don't gotta put another
record out for the rest of his life all
right he's paid because he he's snoop
dogg you wanna get to that point where
people think it's too rare and they're
like we just want to be in the two air
business even when i think of snoop dogg
i think of the movies he plays that's
what i mean you think of movies you
think of the commercials you think of
his tv [ __ ] like
you know like you want people to kind of
you want to have like seven different
groups of fans people who like it for
your music people who [ __ ] with you
because of tick tock people who [ __ ]
with you because they saw you on this
new tv show
all that [ __ ] man
how are you gonna not become a one-hit
wonder bro
i'm already not a one-handed wonder well
listen i don't think i i i don't know if
you got a hit yet
you got to get that platinum plaque
first yeah i do you right but i mean
like this record seems to be
yeah on that path
how do you not become one of those like
you know we see a lot of guys come and
go how do you how do you make sure you
have longevity in the game i stay
consistent
yeah just stay in that studio keep
cooking up keep doing beneficials
[ __ ] for a frog you know
the right collapse
yeah it's about being strategic when you
drop what about your writing process are
you writing [ __ ] down are you just are
you kind of punching in i be writing
hooks sometimes but i'm on the punching
like i'm in a punching phase right now
like cupid i punched him with that [ __ ]
will you like do the melody first
like hum a melody and then punch in or
you just yeah yeah yeah i do that or i
just go like larry got the lyric type
[ __ ] fire yeah
yeah i feel like punching it is the new
way every rapper i see it there
everyone's punching it yeah punching is
i ain't gonna lie anything i was gonna
never be able to get that [ __ ] down pet
cuz i used to write music is it harder
to remember your own verses when you
punch in as opposed to writing them down
it ain't really hard
no because you because you'll keep
telling them like bring it back bring it
back
and then the lines keep playing over and
over yeah that makes sense yeah well
listen the new record is going crazy
yeah for sure cupid go run it up little
dirk is on the record uh did you already
shoot a video for this yeah you dropping
the video i think tomorrow today after
that that's a big deal uh
hopefully kim kardashian hooks you up
with some sort of discount on those
skins you know for your uh for your
complicated girlfriend or your
complicated situation
there it is man too rare appreciate you
bro i appreciate you yes sir fire